Over the last few years we followed, I was
going to call it the evolution, it's really
the the devolution of a Fox host, Maria Bartiromo,
as I told you many times before, way back
in.
When was it way back in?
I guess it was the late 90s when I got into
stocks and stock markets.
She was a really good reporter on CNBC and
did a lot of really interesting things, including
reporting from the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange.
During the Trump era, Maria devolved into
the biggest brownnosing Trump sycophant, perpetuator
and signal booster of a completely not based
in any evidence conspiracy theories about
the election and so much more.
And she is not stopping.
We were wondering, with Trump gone, whether
she would stop because there's no more president
to keep a relationship with, but she's not
stopping.
Here is Maria this weekend saying that in
her view, the big lie is not that Joe Biden
didn't steal the election.
The big lie was the entire Russia story.
Take a listen to this.
Many people still believe that there was collusion
because of the incredible way that they were
able to spread this lie.
They're calling election fraud the big lie.
In my view, this is the big lie, Russia collusion
with Trump.
Here is Maria Bartiromo again, playing up
the idea that Joe Biden is doing something
wrong by not doing the things Trump would
have done if he were still president.
And she cites as an example Trump was about
to put.
These are my words now, his disgraced former
campaign manager, Corey Lewandowski, on the
Defense Advisory Board, something Corey Lewandowski
has no business being involved in.
Biden put a stop to that for Maria.
That's proof that Joe Biden is doing something
wrong.
The book deal.
You can't come and speak at Harvard.
Your import, your point of view doesn't matter
and will not be heard in the public square.
You worked at the Pentagon cash.
And now we know that the Pentagon has stopped
political appointments for any Trump allies
to join defense advisory boards.
It was supposed to be that Corey Lewandowski
and David Bossie were going to be joining
the Defense Advisory Board.
That's been shelved.
They can no longer do it.
And the Pentagon is stopping anybody associated
with Trump from joining these advisory boards.
This is something called elections have consequences.
Corey Lewandowski on the Defense Advisory
Board is nuts.
It never made sense.
Joe Biden rightly put a stop to that because
he won the election.
Imagine if Joe Biden won and didn't say Corey
Lewandowski on the Defense Advisory Board.
Sure.
Let's let it happen.
It would be outrageous if Biden didn't stop
that.
Then Maria interviewed former Trump advisor
Steven Miller, an extraordinarily reactionary
right winger who points to Senator Josh Hawley
losing a book deal with a private book publisher
as being evidence, I guess, of Joe Biden being
bad for president.
Biden has missed a historic opportunity to
make good on his pledge to be a president
for all Americans and to stand up and say
the censorship must stop, the blacklisting
must stop.
We have to listen to and respect all viewpoints
in America.
But he has not done that.
He has turned a blind eye to it.
And what you see when you see people being
denied book deals, when you see people being
denied contracts, when you see people being
banned off of Twitter and Facebook and other
platforms, what you are seeing is a fundamental
erosion of the concept of liberty and freedom
in America, the censorship, the erosion of
liberty and freedom.
First of all, Simon and Schuster saying we
don't want to publish Josh Holli's book is
merely a private company deciding what's profitable
for them.
That's something the right claims to support.
But more outrageously, Holley lost his book
deal while Trump was president.
Trump was banned from Twitter while Trump
was still president.
None of those things were done while Joe Biden
was president.
So obviously at at its face, these are not
examples of censorship.
These are not examples of anything other than
companies deciding what's good for them.
And while they're not assuming they're not
violating any laws, they are acting on that,
acting on their terms of service, etc..
But the really wacky aspect is it all happened
while Trump was president.
Why are we even talking about Joe Biden?
One more clip.
Maria Bartiromo continues to platform deception
about what?
Free speech and censorship, even our concept
of liberty and freedom in America.
Freedom is not just a line on a piece of paper,
Maria Marea, freedom is a culture.
Freedom is a way of life.
Freedom is a way of being.
If we as Americans get to the point where
we're willing to discriminate against people
based on their point of view, be they Republican,
Democrat, conservative, liberal, we have fundamentally
abandoned our core values.
And you're right, it's going to lead to we're
not going to bank with you.
We're not going to give you a mortgage.
We're not going to lease you a car.
We're not going to represent you in a court
of law.
There's no limit here.
This could not be more important.
Please come back.
We'll continue our coverage superimportant.
Steven.
Yes.
Please come back and tell us more about that.
Now, the problem isn't just these shows.
It's that people thinking they're learning
something here.
What I mean by that is the following.
If people were more educated and media literate,
they would know I'm not going to learn a damn
thing about censorship and free speech.
And the First Amendment on Fox News Sunday
morning from Maria Bartiromo and Stephen Miller.
If people were more aware and and conscious
of this being, it's really it's just entertainment
and it's really not that entertaining.
It's entertainment for some people.
They might understand.
Oh, you know, if I want to read about constitutional
law, let me go get the book of Erwin Chemerinsky,
a constitutional law scholar and professor
that we interviewed on the show.
Or if you really want to learn about the First
Amendment, you go and you read the work of
Burt Neuborne, the New York University law
professor, expert on the First Amendment,
who we interviewed on the program.
If you understand what is actual expertize
on these issues and you realize the expertize
on the First Amendment and censorship, it's
not coming from Stephen Miller, it's not coming
from Maria Bartiromo, this stuff wouldn't
be
as dangerous.